die landesverteidigungsakademie und als
kommandant begriff sich zu diesem zeit
zeigen gespräch zum sicherungseinsatz
1991 vielleicht fragen sich der eine
oder andere die eine oder andere warum
gerade die landesverteidigungsakademie
so ein zeitzeugengespräch über den
sicherungseinsatz 1991 durchführt die
landesverteidigungsakademie als die
höchste bildungs und forschungsstätte
des österreichischen bundesheeres hat in
ihrem aufgabenportfolio eben auch die
historie das beschäftigen sie mit
historischen ereignissen und so haben
wir im rahmen unseres institut für
strategie und sicherheitspolitik ein
entsprechendes element das sich damit
auseinander selbst der zeitpunkt 30
jahre nunmehr nach diesem ereignis ist
geradezu ideal um sich mit solchen
thematiken auseinanderzusetzen
sie fragen sich vielleicht warum
einerseits weil nach diesem zeitraum die
beschränkungen die verschlusssachen das
was weggesperrt wurde von der
öffentlichkeit allgemein wieder
zugänglich ist und daher zusätzliche
materialien zur verfügung stehen mit
denen man sich in der forschung
auseinandersetzen kann und zum zweiten
ein ganz wesentlicher punkt dass auch
die zeit zeigen einige distanz zu dem
entsprechenden ereignis haben aber
letztendlich nach wie vor zur verfügung
stehen damit ihre wahrnehmungen nicht
unwiederbringlich verloren sind
und so sind gerade die zeugen dass seit
der zug der suppe
torische ereignisse entsprechend
fundiert und tiefgründig aufzuarbeiten
geschätzte damen und herren nun aber
genug der einleitenden worte ich freue
mich an dem moderator herr hofrat
universitätsdozent dr in schmiedel
nunmehr übergeben zu können und sie sind
ganz sicher so gespannt wie ich auf die
ausführungen unserer zeit zeigen
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren ich
darf sie hier begrüßen zu unserer zeit
zeugen runde zum jahr 1991
mein name ist erwin schmid leitet das
institut für strategie und
sicherheitspolitik an der
landesverteidigungsakademie dean und ich
darf gleich zum beginn bundesminister dr
werner fasslabend den damaligen
verteidigungsminister bieten wie sie
diese aufregenden tage im juni 19 91
erlebt haben vielleicht gleich zu beginn
noch mal muss man vorausschicken der
konflikt oder diese krisensituation war
überhaupt nur möglich weil zwei jahre
davor
der kalte krieg zu ende ging bis dahin
war ein lokales ereignis ein bürgerkrieg
in einem europäischen land fast
undenkbar weil er fast automatisch dazu
geführt hätte dass entweder die
sowjetunion und der warschauer pakt oder
die nato eine derartige situation
ausgenutzt hätten und einmassiert werden
in jugoslawien war so dass circa zehn
jahre nach dem krieg nach dem tod von
titel und eben kurze zeit nach dem ende
des kalten krieges die situation sich so
weit entwickelt hat dass die
unabhängigkeitsbestrebungen in slowenien
und in kroatien so ausgeprägt waren dass
der zusammenhalt des staates nicht mehr
ernstlich in frage gestellt war sondern
wirklich in frage gestellt wurde
natürlich haben wir am anfang nicht
daran gedacht dass es zu einem
bürgerkrieg kommen würde allerdings als
gute beobachter und ich sage
gewissenhafte militärisch
verantwortlichen haben wir uns
selbstverständlich damit
auseinandergesetzt was alles passieren
könnte und so war es auch bei mir
eigentlich habe ich schon unmittelbar
bevor ich überhaupt mein amt angetreten
habe versucht um vorbereitungen für
einen krisenfall jugoslawien weil ich
allein aufgrund meines aufenthaltes im
sommer eines party urlaubs jugoslawien
wo ich das ganze land gefahren bin
schon spüren konnte dass der spannungen
vorhanden waren die sich innerhalb
relativ kurzer zeit den taten würden und
dann war es soweit eigentlich schon ein
paar tage bevor ich ihn gelobt wurde hat
slowenien angekündigt dass sie sich ein
halbes jahr später für unabhängig
erklären wird und wir haben daraufhin
natürlich auch eine vorbereitungen
getroffen um auf eine derartigen krisen
fall vorbereitet zu sein und so geschah
es dann ja und was dann passiert es in
diesen tagen mal natürlich hoch spannend
und zwar deshalb weil unmittelbar nach
der unabhängigkeitserklärung von
slowenien die jugoslawische volksarmee
versucht hat bis an die grenze zu
marschieren alle grenzübertritt stellen
zu besetzen und das mit gewalt das heißt
mit militärischen mitteln es ist dort
bombardiert worden es ist beschossen
worden
es hat tote gegeben um auf der einen
seite eine flucht nach norden nach
österreich zu verhindern und um auf der
anderen seite von norden her slowenien
unter druck zu setzen und das war
selbstverständlich die zeit wo wir nicht
nur reagieren mussten sondern wo wir
auch reagiert haben am anfang so dass
wir schon vorbereitet kräfte in den raum
verlagert haben
aber nicht ganz bis an die grenze
vorgerückt sind
neben der jugoslawischen volksarmee
keinen vorrang zu geben
zum eingreifen das hat sich durch
durchaus bewährt wenn sich auch nachher
nachrichtendienstlich feststellen ist
als es derartige annahme gegeben hat die
zum vorwand genommen wurden um mir die
ganze über slawische volksarmee
sozusagen in den norden zu den zehnten
ab dem moment wo geschossen wurde an der
grenze sind wir dann bis an die grenze
vorgerückt und haben dadurch versucht
nicht nur schutz und sicherheit für die
bevölkerung herbeizuführen sondern
natürlich auch dafür zu garantieren dass
nicht truppen aus dem jugoslawischen
raum die grenzüberschreitend bei uns
weiter kämpfe in österreich oder über
österreichisches territorium dann wieder
zurückgehen um dadurch einen taktischen
vorteil
zu erringen so hat sich die situation
dargestellt
das war natürlich eine situation die
sich nachträglich durchaus leicht
erzählt ist es war politisch insofern
nicht ganz einfach weil es im rahmen der
regierung keine einheitliche auffassung
zur selbstständigkeit von slowenien und
kroatien gegeben hat beiden
koalitionsparteien bvb war dafür die sp
war zurückhaltend und war dagegen
und das hat sich dann auch beim einsatz
so abgespielt das heißt es ist vom
regierungspartner her keine initiative
gekommen
aus dem innenministerium keine
initiative gekommen und ich habe daher
entschlossen habe ich mich daher
entschlossen in einer eigenschaft als
verteidigungsminister einen
einsatzbefehl zu geben und zwar zum
ersten mal einen militärischen
sicherungseinsatz an der grenze zu
verfügen
es war so als ich jetzt den
bundeskanzler angekündigt hatte gesagt
herr kollege
das ist ihre entscheidung und so weiß
auch was man dabei stört es
selbstverständlich dass es in
schwierigen situationen ist man im
wesentlichen auf sich allein gestellt
und muss daher auch alles unternehmen
damit es gut abläuft und das was ich
erfahren habe in dieser situation war
muss ich sagen ein hochqualitatives
bundesheer und zwar von a bis z
das hat beim nachrichtendienst begonnen
denn alle unterschätzt haben die aber
innerhalb kürzester zeit eigentlich
zudem informationsinstrument für ganz
europa geworden ist wo auch die anderen
länder und möchte sich dann daran
orientiert haben
und das war auf der anderen seite der
einsatz am boden und auch in der luft
wir werden ja durchaus hannovers coach
heute noch einiges hören wie schwierig
es war und was war der täter hatten wir
wirklich einen hochqualitativen einsatz
das bundesheer ist vorher in frage
gestanden und zu diesem zeitpunkt war es
dann eigentlich so dass man in den
medien teilweise vom wunder bundesheer
gesprochen hat und das war sicherlich
ein wichtiger ausgangspunkt auch für
spätere reformen oder eigentlich für
unmittelbar anschließend reformen
aber vielleicht reden wir darüber etwas
später vielen herzlichen dank an
minister
ich komme jetzt gleich den zum
bundesheer zum angesprochenen riege der
hass weiter
damals junger oberstleutnant im
generalstab auf truppen verwendung
kommandant das ganze kreative bataillons
achten rang
wie hast du diesen einsatz erlebt ja ich
war damals im wege der truppen
verwendung für generalstabsoffiziere
kommentaren des
panzergrenadierbataillons 9
das panzer geworden und 9 aber damals
vorgesehen zunächst für einen
assistenzeinsatz im burgenland hat dazu
auch die nötigen vorbereitungen bereits
getroffen
mit der eskalation der lage in slowenien
wo wir uns dann ein einsatzraum in
kärnten zugewiesen
präzise gesagt von lavamünd bis seeberg
sattel einschließlich wir wurden dann am
donnerstag den 27
juni alarmiert haben in der nacht mit
der verlegung begonnen und waren am 28
im einsatzraum wie schon erwähnt
zunächst als assistenz partei mit der
ankunft im einsatzraum hat dann das
militärkommando kärnten angeordnet nicht
assistenz sondern militärischer
sicherung sensors gemäß § 2 wer
gesetzlich 3 a nun stand man vor dem
problem dass das assistenz parteien nur
leicht bewaffnet vor ort war
es galt also dass patron nachzurüsten
das ist also in wirklich erfolgen der
art und weise durch das land der region
71 geschehen
und dann wollte ich die schützenpanzer
nachholen
das ist leider ein wermutstropfen das
armeekommando hat das abgelehnt
aus sorge vor einer drohgebärde oder
eine eskalation nun mit 29 sind dann
zwei dinge passiert ein serbisches
panzerbataillon ist von drago grad
richtung grenze österreichischen
staatsgrenze bewegt worden und
gleichzeitig trat die probe gehandelt
bei dem auf dem plan
in beidem wurde österreich beschuldigt
ist eine neutralität aufzugeben und
gemeinsam mit der nato eine intervention
in ex jugoslawien zu planen
das hat dazu geführt dass ich dann doch
noch zu bands und gekommen bin
es wurde nämlich die kampfgruppe 14 also
dass panzer bei der und 14
verstärkt durch ein artilleriebataillon
an die grenze verlegt und dieses
bataillon war zunächst vorgesehen als
mill kommando reserve aber seine
einsatzziele lagen alle im bereich hat
uns auf meine leute sehr beruhigend
gewirkt es hat dann wechseln die
gruppeneinteilungen gegeben weil wir
einerseits an 71 abgaben abgeben mussten
ein patron um die dichte zu erhöhen an
der grenze das war der raum lavamünd und
andererseits eine kompanie abgestellt
haben auf den wurzenpass zusätzlich hat
man uns laufend kräfte unterstützt und
erstellt um die überwachung an der
grenze zu verdichten
das ging dann eigentlich so bis in die
zeit auch der juni mit achten junge
entspannte sich die lage deutlich und
das panzerbataillon 14 wurde zum
beispiel zurückgezogen und auch ein
jäger komponierte und von salzburg
zugeführt wurde hat ebenfalls die zelte
abgebrochen und dann blieben wir noch
bis zum 29
juli im einsatzraum und wurden dann
ebenfalls zurück verlegt und der einsatz
war damit beendet
da wird es jetzt vielleicht nützen für
einen nachhaken der frage an minister
fasse land gerade diese entwicklung hin
von dem doch ein bisschen unerwarteten
beginn zunächst ein assistenzeinsatz
dann sicher als sicherungseinsatz
letztlich bis hin zur entspannung im
juli wird sie das als minister gesehen
ja das war ganz einfach das heißt ich
habe anordnung gegeben einen
einsatzbefehl auszuarbeiten
wir haben allerdings nicht gewartet bis
der tatsächlich fertig war und natürlich
dann auch abgestimmt war
im zuge der regierung sondern haben in
der zwischenzeit bereits die truppen
verlegt
daher sozusagen auch unter dem
gesichtspunkt assistenzeinsatz und erst
dann ist die militärische situation
entstand und das hat durchaus etwas
völlig neues auch für die behörden
es war so dass plötzlich die polizei die
gendarmerie in assistenz zum bundesheer
anfang musste oder auch die
bezirkshauptmannschaften und alle waren
das gegenteil geworden das heißt dass
hier das handy für wohnungen hat dass
die anderen sozusagen zu arbeiten
mussten war eine völlig neue situation
war aber auch durchaus immer
erfahrungsschatz des historischen
bundesheer ist wichtig auf sicht gesehen
um eine entsprechende führungsstärke
auch entwickeln zu können
vielen herzlichen dank ich darf jetzt
auf eine ganz andere ebene kommen
nämlich in die luft
wir haben jetzt die ereignisse am boden
gehört zu den aufregenden ereignissen
gehört mir auch immer wieder
grenzverletzungen gehört ja auch der
eine aufklärungsflug mit 21 über die
südliche steiermark und bis nach graz
des koffers sie waren damals tragen
pilotieren das hautnahe gewissermaßen
durch die cockpit habe erlebt wie oft
mehr weniger ich war damals staffel
kommandant aber auch ausbildungsleiter
für didaktische ausbildung an tragen und
wir waren damals einig eine relativ
kleine gruppe werden vorher einige
abgänge zur linie so waren wir insgesamt
neun piloten wobei nicht alle in der
staffel ihren arbeitsplatz sagte aber
das was da stand ich wurde und als
lehrer unterstützt von einem
schwedischen klären ob die situation hat
sich dann so entwickelt am donnerstag
den 27
dass die ersten luftraumverletzungen
einem grenzraum gegeben und es wurde
dort praktisch geschossen auch und wir
haben mal bei der einsatzzentrale
nachgefragt sollen wir nicht doch
präsent sein und hier gegen wirken wird
der antrag war nahmen wir müssen hier
vorsichtig agieren dass wir hier nicht
zwei drei situationen kommt man da gut
am nächsten tag am freitag in der früh
frage ist irgendeiner miranda nichts und
ich war dann gemeinsam mit unseren
geschwader kommandanten und unserem
technischer offizier beim kommandanten
der flieger division in lange levern um
gewisse probleme im bereich logistik wie
man damals gerade aktuell kopten durch
zu besprechen als der anruf kam dass
geschwaders alarmiert besprechung
abgebrochen
neben damals die 115 viersitzer mit
gehabt zurück nach zeltweg dann müsste
der stellvertretende
geschwaderkommandeur antrag bereits die
der transporter munition und und das auf
munitionieren veranlasst und dann sollen
wir die ersten einsatzbefehle kommen wir
verlegen roten weise es hat immer mit
zwei flugzeugen im zuge von drei flügen
nach klar zu nett auftrags sicherung des
luftraums und und wahrung der
souveränität
ich war dann beim ersten verleger flug
der roten führer und war dann schon
beeindruckend also zuerst muss man sagen
die auf oder es war die aufforderung wir
sollen relativ tief fliegen damit wir
wahrgenommen werden von der bevölkerung
nicht wir haben es uns beim trachten aus
lärmschutzgründen die mindestflughöhe
war 1000 meter für übungsflüge und
nachdem wir alle früher bei 105 auch die
flück gemacht haben war das kein problem
und so dieser magnet club allerdings
muss man sagen es war dann beeindruckend
man sieht ja aus der luft bei ungefähr
850 900 km h zuviel details wir von
kärnten beginnt richtung osten lavamünd
war schon mal die chance da ist es
kracht und brennt und und ob es wird
geschossen und wir stellen dann war
natürlich dort über die grenze die
kleinen grenzstationen haben nicht
erkennen können oder kam aber natürlich
ein spielfeld war auch entsprechendes
szenario noch dazu die aufforderung über
funk das irgendwie vorhin vorbeifliegt
da wo er hingehört und mir sind
weiterhin bedingte große technische
führung
also hat man dort auch geschaut dass man
diese fühlen uns haben wir dann bis zu 1
burg und anregungen
das war beeindruckend ja wir sind wird
von den cluster techniker bereits in
empfang genommen worden die valascia
aufgeschnitten und bei der durch gabe
meines einsatz berichtes an die
einsatzzentrale des armee kommandeurs
hier in wien höre ich ein flugzeug das
mit hoher geschwindigkeit an sich
ernährt und immer gedacht komisch ist
jetzt einer von uns oder was ist jetzt
passiert und dann schaue aus dem fenster
sehe den nordteil der piste wie eine mig
21 und inzwischen gemerkt das ist der
sieg war mit hochgeschwindigkeit den 50
meter ungefähr die piste entlang fliegt
dann hoch steigt nach westen abkunft und
dann weiter richtung süden wieder
verschwindet dann und das über telefon
durchgeben und bringt ihr damals
bestätige das war mit 20 100 prozentig
nennt mit mit blau weiß rote streifen
auf der der finnen na gut ja er hat
unsere zweite rote wurde
die war schon in der luft aus zeltweg
macht sogleich angesetzt aber das war
die entfernung zu kurz um das aufzuholen
und dann hat das ganze andere dynamik
bekommen
es ist dann relativ rasch der
einsatzbefehl oder befehl kommen einsatz
gemäß § 2 und das muss so war dann eine
wesentliche erleichterung in allen
abläufen nord mehr spielraum bekommen
es waren maßnahmen seinen leichter
durchzusetzen gewesen weil es hat sie
innerhalb kürzester zeit im grenzraum
beispiel fällt
ein flug tourismus entwickelt es wurden
reporter haben die flieger chartered und
haben geschaut das ist wohl kann man mit
die luftaufnahmen machen und das muss
man sich vorstellen
manfred patrol immer schaut dass man die
grenzen nicht überschreitet man achtet
auf die luft haben sie beobachtungen
machen was weise gegenseitig decken und
dann der fahrer hast überflieger
verdienen das wurde es dann rasch
abgestellt dass hier ein sperrgebiet
entwickelt wurde aufgestellt wurde
wir haben am anfang auch ehrlich gesagt
die frage der der rules of engagement
der einsatzregeln war zuerst der zeit
carsten jung nur not werden nach japan
musste warten bis einer wirklich schießt
wir haben dann über die
nachrichtendienste erfahren dass die
lage für die soldaten der volksarmee
eben doch so ist dass das mehr oder
weniger österreich nato eine bedrohung
darstellen sollte jetzt weiß aber nicht
wie es der aufgeschreckten in einem
flugzeug nicht gegenüber was hat der
mann schon mal mehr oder weniger 30
kilometer 40 kilometer nur österreich
einbringen was man nicht wir haben also
dann entsprechende informationen
entwickelt taktiken gefechts taktiken
techniken mit denen wir heute dann
versucht haben das zukunft soweit
möglich zu kompensieren und und
entsprechend die effizienz
sicherzustellen
ein problem war natürlich zu dem
zeitpunkt dass wir damals nur die
bordkanone hatte also ungefähr gleich
wie legal aus dem zweiten weltkrieg
und natürlich die mix entsprechend
besser ausgestattet worden mit
kurzstrecken lenkwaffen zumindest nicht
wenn jetzt wenn auch gerade lenkwaffen
mit der größeren reichweite gehen und
wir haben dann am sand
und denen wir gesprochen es muss
irgendwas eingeleitet werden die skater
zukunft hat also die effizienz von dem
system ohne kurze mindest kurzstrecken
lenkwaffen ist es nicht gegeben
dann das nächste problem weil wir waren
wie gesagt neun piloten die es war ich
da zu dem zeitpunkt weil ich der einzige
der eine komplette taktische ausbildung
gehabt habe eben weil ich lange in
schweden war und die anderen piloten und
sich aus zwei ausbildungsgruppen ergeben
wo eben die ausbildung stände noch
teilweise sehr aufhalten die wahren
bereich auf luft taktik wir haben heute
also hier zumindest eine klare einfache
maßnahmen diskutiert oder oder
festgelegt damit jeder damit umgehen
kann und das nächste aber auch noch eine
anfang und warum eigentlich die führung
im grenzraum durch das militärischen
million cc das military coordination
control center in wien erfolgt und nicht
wie wir es gewohnt wurden durch die
radler leid offiziere
das sollten wir dann auch rasch vergeben
normalerweise in der ezb in st dann
sitzen die radarpistole dienst und das
land endlich in unseren partnern boden
wenn es um taktische einsätze geben das
würde dann auch die frau schon
eingespielt
die schwierigkeit war natürlich dann
einen 24 stunden betrieb aufrecht zu
erhalten
mit drei roten am tag eine in höchster
bereitschaft spricht die piloten und
wirklich anzogen waren irgendwas vorsitz
bereitschaft und zu tragen war sehr
rasch reagieren können als bereitschaft
die die zweite rote auch voll attestiert
und die dritte rote war ein anderer 30
minuten ging bereitschaft in der nacht
wurde reduziert auf eine rote weil auch
im von der jugoslawischen armee keine
aktivitäten worden
das war mal so die kasse szenario hat
sie dann wie der praktische aussprachen
hat
mitte juli hat sie das beruhigt also wir
waren immer im einsatz wenn praktisch
ein flug ziel von süden erkannt wurde
richtung grenze hat man uns spiel recht
dazu geführt wir sind einfach so
geflogen dass man wie run auf unsere
fahrer eindeutig zu sehen sind damit man
auch eventuelle überschreite
grenzüberschreitende flüge erkennen kann
und eine eventuelle bedrohung daraus
ableiten kann
und auch wir gesehen wären nicht für das
jugoslawische rider damit wir sehen
heute hier sein und tatsächlich war es
so dass es dann keine grenzen verletzung
im zuge von kampfhandlungen geben mehr
gegeben hat nicht es würde auch
respektiert also die haben immer abstand
von zehn kilometer fünf bis zehn
kilometer eingehalten und könnte man
schon sagen dass das eine folge dieser
präsenz der tragung bzw opfern geht ja
im luftraum leider ganz aber das war
sicher so weil eben wie gesagt wir dann
zu geflogen sondern dass man uns auch
gesehen hat und es wurde auch bestätigt
es war vor fünf jahren im spielfeld oder
symposien bc 25 jahre grenzeinsatz unter
waren zwar slowenisch offiziere die
damals im einsatz waren ein teil der bei
den territorial kräften und in bestätigt
durch die regelmäßige präsenz der tragen
an der grenze hat keine luftangriffe
mehr geben im grenzland dass dieser raum
war dann für sie befriedet und am boden
man in den zugriff der nette haben sie
konzentrierte haben sie mehr oder
weniger ziemlich schikanieren kennen mit
abregelung hinten der versorgung und was
jetzt über solche maßnahmen wird er dort
ganz gut erklärt und da zeigen wir haben
also unsere aufgabe den schutz der
souveränität meiner meinung nach sehr
gut wahrnehmen können damit vielen
herzlichen dank herr obermann wir jetzt
gewissermaßen zu einer vierten dimension
wir hatten die politik wir hatten den
militärischen einsatz am boden
militärischen einsatz in der luft die
rolle der medien
1991 war auch ein medienkrieg die medien
sehr stark instrumentalisiert vor allem
von slowenischer seite
sie waren damals junger redakteur ich
kann mich an das bild erinnert mit dem
mikrofon
direkt in grenznähe wie haben sie diesen
einsatz erlebt gibt es nicht gefunden
der orf hat gefilmt die wurde ja
wünschen hoffnungen ich bin da
einigermaßen hineingestolpert sozusagen
denn da hingeschickt noch lavamünd leben
und sie erfahren dahin mit seinem radio
reportage schwanger des christian
steiner tage waren zur grenze und jemand
eigentlich nur noch wenig gedacht und
dann sehen wir dort ein kameramann der
so hinter der mauer kauern war ein
klares selbst das low vene und des
wohlstandes studio gedreht hat und der
war schon dort
und der zeigt nur so wir sind
stehengeblieben und wie wir dort
aussteigen sehen wir drüben wie das des
grenzgebäude in graach war das trend ok
und da hast du also das tut sich doch
was und dann mal ganz so schlimme szene
die der weltweit überall gesehen wurde
wo dieses soldaten mit einem weißen tuch
oder radfahren herauskommen soll wachsen
und der stolpert bei einer stolpert und
wie der stolpert beginnen die anderen zu
schießen und haben den richtigen
geschossen und da es sonst anderswo
haben wir bewusst da ist das mehr los
und dann ist irgendwann ich glaube das
war auch das war der 28 29 28 ist
plötzlich eine mig aufgetaucht das haben
wir dann gesehen mit einer unglaublichen
geschwindigkeit da hat man gemerkt wie
schnell solche flugzeuge sind und wie
schnell es geht
das war zog und wieder zurück und dann
hat er dort in die traufe eingeschlossen
so fontaine auf das war in einer
geschwindigkeit dass alle das nicht
mitkriegt da man damals musste wie
schnell das gehen kann und dann sechs
minuten später sind dann wirklich tragen
aufgetaucht es war ein bisschen
beruhigen
in der tat und das war dann auch die
soldaten dort gewesen das waren rekruten
glaube das meiste die hypernervöse die
waren sehr angespannt
ich glaube die haben einfach ein wenig
erfahrung gehabt es verständlich weil
ein hat mir dann sogar irgendwie der
versucht festzuhalten das war dann hab
ich uns auseinander hat sich dann
entschuldigt so alles voll in ordnung
sondern also überlegte offiziere dann
die das dann alles sehr gut beruhigt
haben dann schon besser gesehen die
waren offenbar schon da die waren so
busch versteckt darüber journalist oder
mattiert das war glaube ich für die
bevölkerung wirklich sehr wichtig und
wir sind dann jugendlicher übermut
irgendetwas wieso das will ich bin dann
auf die slowenische seite
wenn wir dort angewandt habe ein
reporter und ein mitgenommener der
slowenische seite über die grenze und
sondern bis zur front und das hinkriegt
aber da habe dann gemerkt
die sind ja da in uniform haben jetzt
geschlafen ihm gesagt haben gott in der
nacht gefecht gehabt und so das war so
klaviermusik und die meisten haben
schlicht und einfach geschlafen am boden
und ich die waren sehr nett zu uns
gesagt ja wir jetzt schon aufpassen und
so ich weiß noch in die geht und so
stück muss wie ein vollidiot natürlich
und plötzlich ist miranda mehr oder
minder zu boden und sagen ob ich
verrückt bin wieder voll in minenfeldern
das war soldat slowenischen der trojaner
mit immer eigentlich immer das leben
gerettet
das ist war schon das hat mir dann dass
er es bewusst gemacht was da los ist und
dann habe ich prompt den mittags schon
allein stieg voll versammelt weil man
dann erst zu bewusstsein gekommen
du bist hier nicht das ist kein spaß es
ist krieg und insofern ist das schon ein
eindrückliches erlebnis gewesen
und ja gar nicht bestätigen und es hat
deutlicher glaube ich eine psychologisch
extrem wichtige bedeutung gehabt für die
menschen die da warner gesagt kommt es
eben da man wollte sie wahrscheinlich
abhalten weil davor zwei deutsche
urlauber trotz des brennenden zollhaus
es der slowenischen seite zollfrei
einkaufen wollten dass man alle
mitkriegt haben war dieser schreckliche
sache in haibach oder nick vogel in
dieser reporter mit einem daran getan
den flughafen eine forderung kommt
abgeschossen wurde von mir ja dann
radanovic lassen
darf ich vielleicht aus der schilderung
also vielen herzlichen dank nochmal zu
minister fasslabend kommen
diese unterschiedliche wahrnehmung die
präsenz des bundesheeres an der grenze
war sicherlich sehr wichtig für das
sicherheitsgefühl der bevölkerung
beruhigen hat sicherlich einen positiven
einfluss gehabt auf der anderen seite
haben wird die höhere ebene in wien mit
den informationen auch der
nachrichtendienste das eigentlich keine
gefahr droht das muss ja für sich ein
bisschen zu einem spiel gewesen sein
diese beiden ebenen miteinander in
verbindung zu bringen
zweifelsohne war das immer ganz ganz
also aus meiner sicht was das wichtigste
die übersicht über die lage zu bewahren
das heißt wie ist die gesamtlage welche
bedrohung ist vorhanden und was müssen
wir auf der anderen seite tun um eben
der bevölkerung das nötige subjektive
sicherheitsgefühl zu geben und ich
glaube das ist an sich durchaus recht
gut gelungen
das heißt wir haben wir bei
verschiedenen entscheidungen durchaus
überlegt ob man eben verstärken soll
oder es war die frage
1 kommentar hat den antrag gestellt zu
mobilisieren etc
dass da nicht stattgefunden hat weil
bereits die jugoslawische volksarmee
soweit im rückzug begriffen war dass das
ganz im gegenteil auch international
geführt hätte das heißt das war der eine
punkt auf der anderen seite haben wir
den einsatz dann auch noch länger
durchgeführt das heißt nicht nur bis zur
beendigung der kämpfe im heutigen
slowenien die leute haben wir damals
noch nicht unterschieden zwischen
slowenien und kroatien nicht höchstens
an der küste dann etc sondern die kämpfe
sind damals noch in kroatien weiter sehr
intensiv oder noch in viel intensiver
nach weitergeführt worden und wir haben
daher bis zum ende durchgeführt an sich
das kann ich das auch verraten hätten
wir vielleicht schon eine woche vorher
abgebrochen
aber da mussten wir noch
schnell ein baumarkt durchführen über
den feldweg der lage bei uns verbringen
wozu wir vorher keine rechtliche
möglichkeit hatten und das hat mir doch
rechtzeitig untergebracht
vielleicht noch eine frage die
anschließend darf sie am angesprochen
die frage der mobilmachung der
einberufung zur miliz wurde an die
entscheidung verein und eine frage die
auch aufgetaucht ist die weiter behalten
der ausgebildeten grundwehrdiener vom
einrücken termin jänner die dann ende
juni mitten in der krise entlassen
wurden
die frage der miliz die hat sich
eigentlich relativ bald nach beendigung
oder ja eigentlich schon kurz vor
beendigung des einsatzes gestellt das
haben wir sehr gewissenhaft geprüft
gesagt dass jetzt jeder zeit bereit
gewesen jetzt notwendig gewesen wäre
die miliz einzusetzen wir sind
allerdings davon ausgegangen dass es
nicht notwendig war und dass wir mit dem
präsidenten kräften durchkommen
und natürlich hätte mit in der
urlaubszeit man muss sich vorstellen
kärnten war voll von touristen jetzt da
eine mobilisierung was das bewirkt hätte
in der stimmung der bevölkerung das
heißt dass wir keine verbesserung der
subjektiven sicherheitsgefühls gewesen
sondern eindeutig eine verschlechterung
wenn da jetzt plötzlich alle einbezogen
das hätte gefahr signalisiert das zweite
war die frage
die ist eigentlich erst jetzt
aufgetauchte muss man sagen die frage
der abrüstung sozusagen ordnungsgemäß
und des einsatzes im wesentlichen des
april jahrganges das april anregung der
mit das ist vom generalstab sehr
intensiv geprüft und und diskutiert
worden
man hat sich dazu entschieden sozusagen
um das ganze möglichst ordnungsgemäß
über die bühne zu bringen und aufgrund
der tatsache dass es ja eben kein kampf
einsatz war sondern sicherung einsatz
dass man durchaus diese vorgangsweise
gewählt hat noch dazu muss man sagen wo
das verhält des berufs
soldaten und rekruten 10 zu viel war
das heißt auf zehn rekruten sind vier
berufssoldaten gekommen heisst im
durchschnitt auf zweieinhalb auf
zweieinhalb rekruten ein beruf soll dazu
dass sie eben auch eine derartige dichte
in der führung da war dass man das
entsprechend vertreten konnte das war
die grundlage
und ich glaube das war durchaus auch
richtig so das was wir daraus lernen
können sie sicherlich dass eben die
miliz entsprechend vorbereitet werden
muss
miliz hat immer eine anlaufzeit bis sie
sozusagen in den einsatz tatsächlich und
direkt hinein gehen kann und das ist
durchaus ein verdienst der jetzigen
führung das mit ihren beziehungen
eingegangen ist und versucht auch
sozusagen die milizionäre einsatz zu
führen um das effektiv aus nicht nur
auszuprobieren sondern auch zu lernen
was man tun muss um hier den raschen
einsatz besser zu ermöglichen
ja vielen herzlichen dank herr minister
darf ich jetzt mit dieser schilderung
des einsatzes mitten in der
urlaubssaison gleich zu dir kommen
lieber bringen wirst du denn dieses
umfeld wahrgenommen sind dass da zwei
welten parallel irgendwo eigentlich
nicht denn die zivilbevölkerung oder
wirklich heilfroh dass wir endlich in
den einsatzraum gekommen sind um zu
zeigen wie froh man war lässt sich als
beispiel anführen dass beispielsweise
urlauber als pension einquartiert wurden
um uns adäquate unterkünfte zu
ermöglichen
zweitens der zivilbevölkerung hat
unkontrolliert zu kochen und zu zu und
mit den zuschuss begonnen so dass wir
das was in den feldküchen gekocht wurde
gezwungen worden abzugehen und die
gasthäuser verfügen der henkel bekommen
die kunden am nächsten tag auf den
kartenleser sowie ein vortrag gekommen
das war wirklich großartig und aus der
herr bundesminister erwähnt hat die drei
monate hat
an der grenze geschickt worden also
darauf dass nach telefoniert nun ist
würde bis zu einem hohen maße egal ist
hier durch die hohe kader dichte es war
so bei jeder infanterie gruppe ein
unteroffizier kommandant und ein
jüngerer unter pc oder höherwertige
charge als stellvertreter oder auch als
bedienung für das maschinengewehr
es war sicher das problem dass mit
beginn des einsatzes als wir müssen bei
unseren sport begonnen haben man die
grundwehrdiener in ihrer zuversicht
bestärken musste ich habe so sehr
aufgemuntert
es wird vielleicht dann dazu geführt
dass in der phase wo sich die lage
entspannt hat der übermut gestiegen ist
man wieder dämpfen musste vor allem aus
um die angst daher kam dann der übermut
und auch das überlegenheitsgefühl weil
unsere soldaten gesehen haben wie gut
sie ausgerüstet sind spielt er ist ein
wirklich ausgezeichnete sturmgewehr und
demgegenüber die territorial armee mit
ihrer ausrüstung
also das war ein bisschen problematisch
aber konnte entwicklung durch die hohe
dichte problemlos bewältigt werden was
sehr erfreulich war und auch die
zuversicht der soldaten gestärkt hat war
die versorgung die versorgung hat
wirklich hervorragend funktioniert jetzt
kommen natürlich wie manche bemächtigt
haben wir stellen ja es war die gesamte
heeres versöhnung aufgeboten um nur ein
paar verbände zu versorgen iris es darum
was funktioniert hat
ganz im gegenteil zu den unkenrufen die
es durch immer gegeben werden darf ich
vielleicht zu der frage stimmung und
unten ruf kommen herr oberst gerade die
beschaffung der tag ein abfangjäger
hatte in den 80er jahren für ziemlich
viel aufregung gesorgt bis hin zu den
volksbegehren einer steirischen
landeshauptmanns und 1991 hat dann die
stimmung relativ schnell umgeschlagen
haben sie das auch wahrgenommen jetzt
einfach im persönlichen umfeld in der
kommunikation mit den mitbürgern
durchgangs nicht vorbei
ich persönlich das glück hatte ich war
ja in den der beschaffungs zeit oder die
vorbereitungen war ich über zwei jahre
in schweden habe eine familie mit gehabt
also angesichts des vorbeigegangen
wir haben gesagt herr unten ganz wurscht
was du agiert wird
wir schauen dass wir jetzt die den
aufbau entsprechend möglich machen ist
wenn jetzt so leicht es war klar dass
die baustelle noch nicht ganz fertig in
sollte ich sowieso dann im zeitlich die
kurze durch die kürzere piste also waren
etliche voraussetzungen zugänglich
werden uns wirklich sehr stark
konzentriert auf den aufbau des
flugbetriebes in der entsprechenden
qualität und dann war wieder einmal
interview weil wir einige welche
besetzungen dann was heute von der piste
mit luftballons und was ist was auf
jedenfalls waren wir dann da raus und
dann damit minister licher zu einer
besprechung und er hat gesagt ihr habt
mal nicht so genannte schaut das fliegt
und die heutige brücken frei wie man
clean wenn man quasi einen ort sofort an
dieser operation
unser landeshauptmann kleiner film
protestiert dass hinten ein und erklärt
was sache ist die berühmte normative
kraft des faktischen und wir haben
wirklich also man muss von den
agitationen irgendwie ausbeuten und auch
nicht mehr beeinflussen lassen
doch anderen 1 also auch diesen einsatz
interessanterweise der wind anders
gewählt und der war wie ein wilder
wir haben das dann merkt bei den
flugtagen den mann dann angefangen haben
wo helle begeisterung war für den
auftrieb der tragen und das war
natürlich auch wohltuend zweifelsohne
und der vermeintlich diese begeisterung
war mir irgendwie mit um bedrohungen bis
zum ausscheiden
das weiß auch immer wieder spürbar mit
der männer gesorgt bei der parade fährt
es als super der tragen verbaut da
kassiert dafür vielleicht zum abschluss
noch einmal auf die rolle der medien zu
sprechen kommen denn die konfrontation
in slowenien ist farm zu einem guten
teil auf dem fernsehschirm stadt und
letztlich natürlich auch die reaktionen
ist
wenn sie das war ein bisschen
zurückblicken auf auch ist das so es ist
ein halbes jahr nach dem golfkrieg nicht
wo wir alle noch die bilder in
erinnerung kommen dass kreis over bagdad
ist es so ein bisschen eine
wasserscheide in damit ja ein
berichterstattung auch ich denke dass
das dass es zum ersten mal war das
österreichische medien unmittelbar mit
krieg konfrontiert war
insofern ja und in der rezeption war es
natürlich so dass wir konfrontiert und
mit slowenischen heimat treu und logisch
nur diese position vertreten haben wir
haben sehr wohl bemerkt dass die dass
die soldaten nicht wo hätten die wollten
nicht geben von gewissen haben es doch
nirgendwo zu gelandet und so das haben
wir mitbekommen auch wenn wir mit denen
geredet haben die man eigentlich alles
erlebt was soll das ist ja viele
doktoren hängen auch hautnah mitbekommen
in seinem gstaader dass das jetzt alles
sei also das war so ist hier die
gemengelage wo man sich ein journalist
ein bisschen schwer getan hat das
einzuordnen
und wir haben natürlich möglich versucht
jemand der halt zu bleiben klarerweise
bei österreich im fokus aber wir haben
schon auch relativ schnell bemerkt
wahrscheinlich auch durch informationen
wie sie einst gespielt haben dass das
ganze nicht so heißt es wie es zunächst
ausgesehen hat und dass sich das e
beruhigt das war dann doch statt zu
spüren dass ich das ins in der
jugoslawische verlagert das war dann
klar dass der konflikt dort weitergeht
aber wir waren zum ersten mal
konfrontiert mit krieg kann man sagen
seit dem zweiten weltkrieg nicht
logischerweise nicht mitbekommen aber wo
wir bemerkt haben es geht sehr schnell
um leben tod und das war glaube ich eine
zäsur die wir mitbekommen haben dass es
nicht selbstverständlich ist und
deswegen glaube ich war auch die rolle
des bundesheers eine wichtige als
friedensstifter und nicht als
kampfeinheit sondern als kluge
prophylaxe wenn ich das jetzt auch so
von ihnen höre denke ich mir wie viel
man sich da überlegt hat das ist ja doch
militärisch sehr durchdacht dass wir uns
nicht zu klar was da alles
in strategisch vor sich geht umso
schöner ist für mich jetzt in der
retrospektive zu hören was sie sich
derweil legt respekt meine her
ich danke ihnen ein
ich glaube dass auch der punkt wo wir
jetzt langsam dann schluss machen werden
danke ihnen allen für die mitwirkung bei
dieser zeit zeugen runter herr minister
faßler bringe dir hast weiter herr
oberst kovac und günter meyer ich glaube
das was schon wichtig ist wenn wir das
auch bedenken es ist einerseits dieser
einsatz des bundesheeres 19 91
der bisher einzige sicherungseinsatz zur
landesverteidigung das unterscheidet ihn
von all den anderen assistenzeinsätze
von der ungarn krise über die
tschechoslowakei krise bis zu den
anderen und es andererseits natürlich
auch der krieg in slowenien auch wenn er
nach zehn tagen zu ende ging durch die
vermittlung der damaligen europäischen
gemeinschaften der auftakt zu den
blutigen kämpfen umzufallen jugoslawien
die dann letztlich bis heute nachwirken
plötzlich auch mit militärischen präsenz
von friedenstruppen auch unter
österreichischer beteiligung
ein punkt den man vielleicht noch auch
erwähnen sollte werden jetzt gehört das
bundesheer im einsatz an der grenze mit
einem höchststand von über siebeneinhalb
1000 man die hier im grenzgebiet im
einsatz standen man muss bedenken dass
damals gleichzeitig seit august 1990 der
assistenzeinsatz an der ungarischen
grenze stattfand im grenzgebiet nach dem
fall des eisernen vorhangs dass zwei
bataillone im auslandseinsatz standen
eines in zypern und eines in syrien dazu
noch kleinere beobachter kontingente und
andere eine kompanie in kuwait und das
gleichzeitig ein feldspital zur
unterstützung für kurdische flüchtlinge
im nordiran eingesetzt war das heißt das
also hier gleichzeitig so um die 10.000
mann im einsatz waren und auch geführt
worden also etwas was für
österreichische dimensionen doch eine
ganz beachtliche größenordnung ist ja
ich danke allen teilnehmern an diesem
kurzen aber ich glaube sehr
interessanten zeitzeugengespräch
danke ihnen sehr geehrte damen und
herren für das zuschauen und darf noch
einen schönen nachmittag wünschen
dankeschön